في مشهد تاريخي لم يتكرر منذ عام
1923 فشل مجلس النواب الامريكي في انتخاب
رئيس له بعد جوله تصويت ثالثه لانتخاب
رئيس له وعلق المجلس جلساته الى
ظهر الاربعاء بتوقيت واشنطن وكنا قد تم
ترشيحه كل من كيف نكرتي زعيم الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه
وحكيم جيفرز زعيمه الديمقراطيه والجمهوري
جوردن للمنصب وفي الجولات الثلاث لم يتمكن
مكارثي من تامين المئتين و18 صوتا
المطلوبه
للتولي على رئاسه
لمتابعه تنضمي الي من الكونجرس مراسله
الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك مرحبا بيسان مثل
ما ذكرنا في الخبر هو مشهد تاريخ لم يتكرر
منذ عشرات السنين نود ان نفهم الخلفيه ان
امكن والخطوات
المقبله ايضا في ظل هذا التعليق الذي
علينا هو الكونفرس ما الذي سيحدث بعده
نعم محمد الذي سيحدث هو ربما خلال هذه
الساعات التي تفصلنا عن موعد انعقاد مجلس
النواب من جديد في الساعه 8:00 مساء
بتوقيت الدوحه من يوم الاربعاء قد يكون
هناك محاولات جديده لاقناع المعارضين
لترشح مقارتي العشرين عضوا جمهوريا والذين
صوتا للسمالاتهم ربما بتقديم المزيد من
التنازلات من قبل رغم انه كان قد تفاوض مع
مجموعه منهم على مدار شهرين منذ نوفمبر
الماضي بعد انفذ الجمهوريون بالاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب في الانتخابات الاخيره وكان
قد قدم تنازلات ولكن يبدو انها لم تكن
كافيه ال- الحلقه الاخر او ربما السيناريو
الاخر هو بروز اسم جديد او التفاف المزيد
من تعميم القاسي الى
اردن الذي برز اسمه اليوم
كمرشح رغم ان جنجر اردن يسر انه غير مهتم
برئاسه مجلس النواب اعينه على ترخص اللجنه
القضائيه في الكونجرس الجديده وفي مجلس
النواب الجديد كي يفتح تحقيقات كان قد وعد
بها الجمهوريون في اداره رئيس بريده همم
ربما ستكون هناك بعض المداولات خلف
الابواب المغلقه من الان حتى ساعه انقاد
المجلس قد تغير من المشهد الذي شهدناها
اليوم يوم غد طبعا انعكاسات كل هذا هو انا
المجلس معلق همم لا يستطيع مجلس النواب
تسير اي من اعماله دون انتخابه رئيسا لا
يعني ذلك همم الاعضاء الذين اتوا اليوم
ليتلوا بالقسم الدستوريه مع همم انعقاد
هذا المجلس الجديد لدورات الجديده ال18 لم
يستطيع المجلس ان همم ان يسير مراسم همم
القسم سبب انتخاب رئيس
ايضا هناك حزما من القوانين التي يجب ان
تمرر في مجلس النواب كي تسير اعمال المجلس
بشكل عام هذه الحزمه لم تمرر ايضا المتوقع
هو اعلان من سيتراس اللجان اللجان التي
ستسير العمل التشريعي هنا ايضا هذا الامر
لا يمكن ان يحدث قبل ان يتم التوافق
ونشكره رئيس جديد لان مجلس لذا مجلس
النواب من يكون له اي عمل قبل انتخاب رئيس
الديمقراطيون كانوا في موقع المتفرج على
ما شاهدناه ربما حاله فوضى في الجانب
الجمهوري حول كيف اشكرك على كسر الامور
خلال الاشهر القادمه